Olá a todos é um prazer est com vocês
novamente mais uma live Boa noite Carlos
Boa Noite Marta Boa noite Manuel Me dê
um feedback eu tô sem aquele meu
microfone de headset que tava utilizando
nas últimas lives eu tô no outro
consultório queria saber de vocês se
vocês estão me ouvindo
bem e para quem não sabe eu terminei lá
de fazer o documento das lives
anteriores desde 2022 nós temos agora os
resumos de todas as lives com as
perguntas e
respostas e também cada um dos vídeos
tem marcação de tempo para vocês
avançarem no ponto do vídeo que
interessa para
vocês eu estou estou o qu Manuel
escutando bem é isso tá ouvindo bem a
minha voz é isso você tá querendo
dizer Carlos diendo com excelente só que
bom então vamos continuar bem pessoal
hoje eu não tenho preparado nenhum
artigo para vocês que hoje foi bem
corrido e ontem o tempo que seria para
eu preparar o artigo eu gastei fazendo
lá o documento tá porque é bem
trabalhoso fazer mesmo com inteligência
artificial é bem trabalhoso fazer aquela
catalogação de todos as lives que foram
feitas tá
ã som não está com tanta qualidade é
porque não tô com o microfone próximo do
da boca tá mas dá para entender tudo
isso que é importante viu Eliseu Beleza
então vamos dividir a tela aqui com
vocês deixa vou ampliar aqui
está dando para olher a tela né
pessoal Creio que sim né primeira
pergunta Doutor recentemente um médico
americano publicou um vídeo onde ele
dizia que desobstruiu as artérias do pai
utilizando a enzima lipase que deveria
ser ingerida em jejum pela manhã em
cápsulas gastrorresistentes
afirma ele que em se meses reverteu
e mais 70% à obstruções
afirmou que a lipase quando entra na
corrente sanguínea ajuda a retirar a
gordura depositada no endométrio Você
quis dizer não é endométrio tá endotélio
você quis dizer o senhor acredita ser
uma boa estratégia eu nunca ouvi falar
nisso tá nunca ouvi falar nisso se você
tiver o link desse vídeo por favor me
passa que eu quero olhar porque assim o
que a gente sabe de enzima digestiva se
você ingere enzima digestiva em jejum
sem alimento essas enzimas são
absorvidas em grande parte e elas ajudam
a desinflamar e quebrar
imunocomplexo na corrente sanguínea
agora eu nunca vi essa história que
lipase poderia desobstruir a artéria
Então o que a gente sabe é que as
enzimas digestivas Não lipas
especificamente ingeridas de jejum elas
podem ajudar a desinflamar o organismo
com atua como inflamatório E também como
uma forma de você tratar doenças
autoimunes Ok mas não para desobstruir
artérias Inclusive eu não achei nenhum
relato disso
eh Lógico eu fiz uma pesquisa rápida
Então seria bom se você tivesse o
contato o link desse vídeo para dar uma
olhada depois eu quero ver de onde ele
tirou isso
tá mas a princípio não tem nada que eu
conheça dizendo que que você ingerir
lipase mesmo que seja em cápsulas
gastrorresistentes que poderia retirar a
gordura depositado em paredes arteriais
tá isso é no mínimo questionável
bem a próxima pergunta do
Eliseu sem açúcar sem gordura sem sabor
sem aromatizante sem adoçante sem
corante
sem lactose sem mot dotrina sem STV sem
xilitol isolado e puro algumas lives
atrás pedia você indicação de marcas de
Way que atendessem todos os requisitos
acima você indicou algumas marcas
recentemente o d doct first lançou
suplemento prot da doctors first não
conheço vou até olhar agora ao vivo com
vocês Você considera que esse Wave prote
doctors first também atende todos os
requisitos vamos olhar o bula Tem que
olhar Eliseu vamos lá vamos lá doctors
Earth
Way Ok apareceu
aqui página do doctors
first eu vou interromper o
compartilhamento para dividir com vocês
aqui essa
página do doctors first Ok vamos
procurar aqui
ó vou procurar aqui Way vamos ver se o
que que aparece aqui Way isoprotein sem
sabor vamos olhar esse
aqui vamos ver a bula bula né não é bula
né seria o rótulo
ã tem praticamente muito pouco de
carboidrato 1 g de carboidrato rato
mas técnicos aqui viu Eh eu tô usando um
browser
alternativo que se
chama Brave tá eu acho que ele tá
brigando aqui com com streamar
vocês
escutaram qual foi a última coisa que
escutaram para eu saber que ponto que eu
vou continuar aqui
tá a última coisa que eu vi foi tem um
pouco de carboidrato sim tem um pouco de
carboidrato tem um pouquinho de gordura
Muito pouquinho tá tem a talaa estévia
como aantes né que são educ corantes E
tem também
o chocolate
certo então a maior parte do é um Aroma
Natural tá tá dizendo que é Aroma
Natural do chocolate não é um chocolate
artificial não vocês estão me ouvindo
ainda estão conseguindo me ouvir pessoal
me dá um
feedback
aí ou não
Pessoal vocês estão me ouvindo eu
preciso saber se tá tudo em ordem para
eu dar continuidade
aqui eu não tenho certeza se vocês estão
escutando eu vou instalar aqui o o
Chrome aplicativos
Chrome Talvez seja problem no Browser
ah
sk C
s
alô
[Música]
som vocês estão me escutando agora
parece que sim né Obrigado el falou
voltou né então última coisa parece que
você escutou el foi que tinha pouco
carboidrato
Ah você estava ouvindo né aquela hora
que eu falei porque eu não tava tendo
nenhum feedback
tá bom repetir a resposta toda vamos lá
deixa eu dividir a tela aqui com vocês
de
novo
ah
[Música]
janela cadê onde é que tá
o Acho que mais fácil eu abrir aqui
tá deixa eu abrir de novo isso aqui é
melhor dá só um instante aqui
dividir a tela aqui
Ok pera
aí tá deixar assim
mesmo então Respondendo a sua dúvida de
novo vocês estão me ouvindo agora
né tá vamos lá pelo que ouv da
bula do rtulo do da
ele tem pouquíssimo açúcar pouquíssima
gordura tem sabor sim é saborizado com
chocolate mas é natural ah então tem
aromatizante natural de chocolate mas
tem uma versão sem sabor também o
adoçante que ele tem
é estévia com
talaa Se você comprar a versão sem sabor
não vai ter
corante tem pouquíssima lactose não tem
Maltodextrina
mas mas tem Steve assim só não tem
chilit e é isolado e puro respondido
Eliseu Entendeu
agora posso passar pra próxima
pergunta vou continuar
aqui Dr sobre o vídeo a respeito do
picnogenol Há algum exame que possa
comprovar mesmo que de maneira indireta
os benefícios do picin jonal tem tem
alguns exames que você pode est
verificando
ok que exames seriam esses você pode
pedir por exemplo exame de colesterol
triglicérides HDL porque o pinol ele
ajuda né nesses parâmetros então
provavelmente vai melhorar o rdl
colesterol HDL e o colesterol Total você
pode pedir exam de coagulação sanguínea
como o tempo de coagulação negação
plaquetar isso vai datando um valor
provavelmente
melhor tem também os exames de função
renal creatinina urea glicose que também
vão baixar com o uso do picnogenol de
função hepática também vão melhorar com
o uso do
picnogenol você pode ver o aspecto da
sua pele que não é um exame Laboratorial
mas ela vai est com uma consistência
melhor mais hidratada mais
elástica você pode pedir marcadora de
inflamação como proteína ser reativa que
geralmente vão cair com o uso do
picnogenol e se você tiver acesso a
exames mais
sofisticados você pode estar
utilizando por
exemplo exame de marcadora de oxidação
tá é uma possibilidade que existe exame
de marcação de oxidação são menos comuns
o plano de saúde geralmente não
cobre Porém você pode est também pedindo
Esses exames aí de oxidação marcadoras
de oxidação
Ok próxima
pergunta existe risco de absorver
toxinas ao consumir carne de gado
vacinado com imunizantes que foram
fabricados utilizando RNA mensageiro
então Teoricamente existe o risco sim
porque Essas tecnologias envolvem o uso
de
nanotecnologia que eles usam aquelas
micr vesículas né para poder encapsular
o RNA mensageiro então tem aquela
tecnologia lá eh de microvesicular que
Teoricamente poderiam fazer o shading né
que poderia passar através de de
alimentação ou através de secreções
porém iso é uma uma possibilidade
teórica eu não vi nenhum estudo falando
que isso de fato acontece tá eh mas o
que que eu optaria optaria por comer
carne orgânica tá que
Teoricamente ela vai ter uma chance
menor de ter esse gado vacinado com essa
tecnologia tá bom mas isso é uma coisa
totalmente especulativa como eu tô te
falando eu não conheço nenhum estudo
nenhuma literatura falando que existe
essa situação comprovada de que o o RNA
mensageiro da vacina do Gado passou pro
ser humano
Tá qual é a dosagem mínima de
suplementação que eu considero de B6 B12
e ácido fólico para uso seguro do
Sam B6 de 20 a 50 mg por dia B12 por
volta aí de 1 MG por dia pode ser até de
500 mg e ácido fólico pode ser de 1 MG
na forma de mitil folato até 5
dependendo de cada caso tá então B6 20
50 mg B12 por volta de 500 microg a 1 MG
e ácido fólico na forma de metilfolato
de 1 a 5 mg tá
bom a reposição de dhea ainda deve ser
considerada depois dos 40 anos pois já
foi a suplementação da moda e hoje é
pouco falada bem o Deia é interessante
né porque um hormônio que a ajuda na
massa magra ajuda aumentar massa
muscular ajuda massa óssea ajuda no
sistema imune ajuda na
memória ajuda a melhorar o metabolismo
de carboidratos então tem uma série aí
de benefício só que assim o problema é
que os estudos não são muito robustos tá
tem estudos falando que ele é muito bom
e tem estudos que já falam que não é
essa coca-cola toda não então é
interessante vocês entenderem que eu
reponho o dha na forma de
prasterona quando eu vejo que no sangue
está abaixo 150 Tá bom Só lembrando o
Deia ele é um hormônio que ele é
produzido pelas glândulas suprarrenais
ou adrenais ele atinge o pico por volta
de 25 anos de
idade 20 a 25 anos de idade e após os 40
anos ele vai caindo né
bastante então eu repu assim
porque ele é precursor de vários outros
hormônios como testosterona
estrogênio e além do que eu já falei el
também ajuda na vitalidade na energia
Ok então é interessante sim você manter
um Deia no sangue por volta de 250 se
tiver abaixo 150 eu repia C Tá mas
existe mu muita polêmica a respeito do
Deia tá E só faça isso com
acompanhamento médico
vocês estão me ouvindo Tá tudo em ordem
aqui com o
áudio Boa noite D Alan quando eu tento
fazer jejum às vezes sinto dor de
barriga e dor de cabeça pode ser
sintomas de abstinência de Açúcar dor de
cabeça sim dor de barriga acho que não
como é que é essa dor de barriga você tá
ao vivo Quem perguntou isso aqui deixa
eu ver
colocar na individual aqui para ver quem
perguntou an Renato você tá ao vivo an
Renato tá me
escutando Eu acho que ele não tá ao
vivo então
dor de cabeça pode ser um sintoma assim
de você tá se acostumando tá com jejum
Ok e tá se acostumando com abstinência
de Açúcar agora dor de barr eu creio que
não tá Mas me fala aí agora você tá ao
vivo sim que dor de barriga é essa você
pode dar mais detalhes para mim dessa
dor de
barriga tô aguardando
você responder tá bom que eu sei que tem
um delay aí de 10 a 15 segundos do que
eu falo e quando vocês
escutam deixa eu mudar a tela aqui dois
baria com gases não não creio que isso
seja por conta de deficiência de açúcar
ou com abstinência de açúcar não acho
bem provável inclusive Pode ser que você
ao retirar o açúcar tenha aumentado
alguns tipos de fibras na alimentação e
essas fibras em algumas pessoas que T
tendência a cibo né que é a proliferação
de bactérias no Delgado pode dar esses
gases aí que você tá comentando dor de
barriga com gases misturado com enjou
não há nenhuma evidência que isso
seja abstinência de
Açúcar creio que isso daí pode ser
porque você tá aumentando o consumo de
outras fibras tá E aí isso pode estar
gerando gases ess por causa das
bactérias que estão proliferando em
excesso e estão fermentando esses gases
Ok respondido
Antônio temos dúvidas ao
vivo curioso que a segunda vez que
acontece isso comigo viu
de ficar essa situação aí de o stream
ard sair do ar eu acho que não a
internet tá ruim eu acho que algum
problema lá com eles na central lá no
servidores
deles eu disse que a colonoscopia não vê
pequenas lesões Se for muito pequena
pode não não ver pode passar batido
sim mas
isso não sei parece fora de contexto
essa pergunta aqui
É verdade que em 2012 uma agência de
Proteção Ambiental canadense identificou
artefatos dando tecnologia inúmeras
marcas de produtos alimentares e fez uma
publicação gigantesca sobre isso Hum
acho que não
Eliseu vou checar isso tá vai tá
parecendo Teoria da Conspiração esse
negócio mas vamos checar isso
daí vamos Deixa eu só responder essa
aqui depois a
gente volta para esse para esse tema aí
café descafeinado é maléfico eu não
gosto tá Marta eu acho que processo
químico para retirar cafeína ele é ruim
para nossa saúde tá tem aditivos aí para
tirar o café melhor dizendo tirar
cafeína do café e isso pode ser ruim pra
sua saúde e eu não usaria eh café
descafeinado ou ou não toma café ou toma
menos café cafeinado tá
se as supostas nanopartículas presentes
nos alimentos podem alterar nosso campo
bioelétrico então podem afetar o
desempenho de nosso cérebro já que o
cérebro também possui atividade
elétrica é isso se tiver realmente essas
nanopartículas tá Eu eu duvido n é que
eu duvido que totalmente mas eu acho
muito improvável que essas
nanopartículas estejam aí tão difundidas
aí tá bom assim como Aquela Doutora que
eu falei na Live anterior tá difundindo
aí em aulas né mas eu vou dar uma nessa
informação que tá falando
aí não seria o caso de termos
regulamentações rigorosas para garantir
que as nanopartículas dos alimentos não
afetem a saúde humana sim seria o ideal
Elise deixa eu dar uma olada aqui nessa
história que você falou
aí dá só um instante
esa aí cadê eu
entrei deixa eu ver acho que eu entrei
sim ok
Ixe tô enrolando meu pé toda aqui no fio
[Música]
o que eu tô vendo a respeito dessa
informação de 2012
é que o governo
canadense ele tem estruturas
legislativas e regulatórias existentes
para produtos químicos tradicionais para
avaliar e gerenciar os riscos potenciais
nanomateriais para saúde humana e meio e
meio ambiente Deve ser isso que você
ouviu falar tá então tem o tal de plano
de gestão de produtos químicos do Canadá
que é uma iniciativa do governo para
reduzir os riscos de substâncias para
canadenses e seu meio ambiente embora
não tenha considerado especificamente os
riscos potenciais de nanomateriais
existentes até Aquele momento que fo em
2012 foram coletados dados para
estabelecer uma lista de nanomateriais
resistentes no comércio do Canadá Então
acho que foi isso que tá se
referindo então o Canadá como membro da
ucd participou desse projeto que foi
realizado entre 2011 e 2012 esse plano
de gestão de produtos químicos ok
mas depois eu posso dar uma olhada com
mais calma você tem a fonte dessa
informação
Eliseu Antônio eu não vou eu não vou
desistir do canal não tá aquele vídeo
foi mais um
desabafo e foi um aviso pro pessoal que
eu vou reduzir bastante a produção do
canal tá a não ser que eu encontre um
jeito de passar por cima aí desse
desinteresse das pessoas porque não é
simplesmente um problema de
não porque esse vídeo inclusive que eu
falo que eu vou encerrar o canal tá indo
muito bem mas você tem ideia o vídeo
anterior Tima vez que eu cheguei tava
com 25.000 visualizações esse vídeo do
de eu encerrar o canal o vídeo anterior
que eu fiz storytelling coloquei imagens
ilustrativa falei tudo que não foi um
vídeo que não deu nem uns 5 minutos de
duração tava dando 800
visualizações no primeiro dia e chegou a
1000 e pouco para um canal de 800.000
inscritos Antônio é muito muito pouco
cara é muito muito pouco então assim eu
não sei mais o que fazer para chamar a
atenção do povo tá tá todo mundo muito
desinteressado
muito apático né acho que a palavra é
essa tem um canal desse tamanho eu tive
que dispensar a pessoa que fazer as
edições de vídeo para mim e a pessoa
também que me ajudava com os conteúdos
tá porque tava não tava fechando a foto
seus vídeos sejam seus futuros livros
sim ó Eu eu sempre entendi dessa maneira
viu Antônio sempre entendi dessa maneira
só que tem limite para tudo né eu tava 2
anos dando murro e ponta de faca é muito
tempo cara não é 2 meses é do
anos
Adidas boa hein Adidas acho que você
quis ver o HIV aides né as vacinas que
já existiam estão vindo com proteína
maliciosa é de difícil Antônio é porque
um vírus do HIV aparentemente sofre
mutações muito frequentes tá essa que é
a
justificativa se sempre foi essa
judicativa de ter dificuldade de fazer a
vacina do HIV que um vírus tinha muitas
mutações
isso recupera por favor que eu vou ver
com mais
calma oin oin consegue-se eliminar 50%
da gordura desses olhos sim mas vai
continu ingerindo 50% do resto né que é
ruim não recomendo utilizar esse su só
para você continuar usando óo de soja e
Gir mas se você fora de casa você pode
est utizando ess suplemento
sim sim vai eliminar de qualquer tipo de
gordura que você ingerir não é só da
ruim
Não irc tem melhor acur mc índice de
massa corporal você tá falando isso irc
não conheço
índice não sei dizer vou até dar uma
olhada do que que você tá falando Não
conheço CRC não vamos olhar isso
aqui não não é isso aqui
vamos ver se se eu acho informações
sobre
isso índice de resistência corporal é
isso que ser RC Vamos
ver eu não conhecia
sinceramente índice de redondeza
corporal Ah tá então esse que é o
conceito é uma métrica mais recente que
leva em conta a altura e circunferência
da cintura Ah é relação entre altura e
circunferência da cintura mas não peso
eu não usaria Nem um nem outro eu usaria
BR impedancia tá que é muito melhor ele
fornece uma Estimativa de obesidade
central e da gordura abdominal que estão
mais diretamente ligadas a risco de
saúde como diabetes tipo do e doenças
cardiovasculares vantagem do
melhor preditor de riscos da Saúde
relacionados à gordura abdominal
considera a distribuição de gordura
corporal pode ser mais preciso para
atletas e pessoas
musculosas considerações sobre RC ainda
uma métrica relativamente nova com menos
dados de longo prazo requer medição
precisa da circunferência da cintura as
pontuações geralmente variam de 1 a 15
com a maioria das pessoas entre 1 e 10
Ah eu não usaria isso não eu usaria a b
impedância viu mas eu não conhec isso
aqui
não estudos recentes sugerem que o
RC redondeza corporal é ótimo hein
índice redondeza corporal pode ser o
melhor preditor de mortalidade riscos à
saúde comparação com
Mc no entanto é importante notar que
ambas as tem as suas limitações por
exemplo o irc assim como o Mc pode
superestimar o risco em atletas
musculosos e subestimar o risco em
pessoas idosas
ão quase tão ruim quanto IMC
tá eu não usaria nem nem outro usaria A
bioimpedância tá
bom Ok Renato eu respondi a sua dúvida
Você ficou com mais alguma dúvida sobre
a questão da vacina do
HIV aqui no ambiente de trabalho onde eu
fico a uma cozinha ao invés de lavarem o
copo na pia o pessoal coloca dentro do
lavador de louças para limpá-lo e tá
tudo
certo dentro do lavador de louça tem
lavador de louça no seu trabalho
é eu não tenho nenhuma razão para achar
que o lavador de louças não é confiável
Eliseu Mas eu acho Dá mais trabalho
fazer isso do que colocar do que lavar
na pia viu para te falar a
verdade sobre aquela questão da tatuagem
organismo produz anticorpos contra a
tinta da tatuagem e esse anticorpo vai
atuar também na região da retina da
coroide não o que eu encontrei sobre
isso é que a tatuagem que alguns malucos
fazem diretamente no olho é altamente
prejudicial tá foi isso que eu encontrei
não encontrei nada falando de anticorpo
contra
eh tinta que vai viajar pro olho não tá
isso não vi nada sobre isso isso como eu
já acabei de falar as vacinas que já
existiam como HPV gripe etc estão vindo
com a proteína Spike como a da
cov isso é só uma suposição anônio tem
gente que tá achando que sim
tá tem gente tá achando que eles estão
misturando as vacinas para mesmo quem
não tomou aquela específica né que vai
acabar tendo a prot Spark no corpo de
qualquer jeito eu acho que é uma
teoria bem plausível Apesar de eu não
ter confirmação nenhuma disso daí tá até
que temperatura pode ser usado o mel sem
perder a
qualidade você quer dizer de armaz ento
é
isso eu não aqueceria o mel diretamente
no fogo não você pode aquecer se o m
tiver duro se quiser aquecer no banho
maria é uma boa tá eu acho que a
temperatura do banho maria é é o
suficiente e não vai deteriorar o mel
agora Eu não colocaria o mel diretamente
num na panela esquentaria não tá aí eu
acho que a temperatura demais então faça
isso no banho maria tá
Manuel se a pessoa que sua doença alcar
é devido à tatuagem que fez no olho é
muito doido fazer uma coisa dessa no
olho né considerando que é impossível
remover a tatuagem também será
impossível curar a doença creio que será
impossível
Eliseu no caso de Tipo dois eu vou ter o
mais correto correto é cura ou remissão
vou ter o mais correto é
remissão mandei
manipular 10.000 deve ser unidades né de
vitam e 100 mg de K2 eu posso ao invés
de tomar um comprimido tomar dois e
assim ingerir 20.000 depende Antônio Não
faça isso em acompanhamento que você
pode entrar numa hipervitaminose D para
algumas pessoas 20.000 É adequado por um
bom tempo se ela tiver muita defensa de
vitamina D agora para outras pode ficar
excessivo
beleza na Live retrasada você disse que
a grande maioria do milho no Brasil é
estérico sim A grande maioria a única
maneira de reconhecer o milho não
transgênico é através do Celo orgânico
Brasil
sim eu confiaria na galinha em que a
maior parte da alimentação dela é descar
no chão com isso você refere as galinhas
caipira sim as galinhas
caipira Então porque é o seguinte se
você fizer uma Alimentação adequada você
vai conseguir reverter o diabet mas se
você voltar a alimentação original
inflamatória o Diabetes vai voltar então
você não tem como chamar isso de cura
não é uma cura verdadeira é uma remissão
ou reversão da doença tá esse aqui é o
ponto de conceito que eu quero frisar
com você
aqui mas são justamente as galinhas
caipiras que eu me referi quando
perguntei sobre embalagem de ovos
caipiras que vem escrito que alimentação
das Galinhas é mío
Então mas não é só milho né Eliseu milho
é um alimento predominante mas el Elas
comem outras coisas elas
comem vários bichinhos do chão Elas
comem vários outros alimentos do chão
não é só milho porque o milho é o que é
dado para elas como é a mesma coisa você
não vai ter uma criação de gado que come
pasto predominantemente ess come impasto
e você vai ter que dar uma suplementação
né com
sal sal que eles lá nas creações de gado
né o sal
específico e outras coisas que eles dão
pro gado Então não é que ela vai comer
só o que tá no chão eles dão também o
milho pra Galinha Tá bom agora para ter
mais detalhe você tem que conversar com
o fabricante não né com criador né para
saber que tipo de milhoes estão dando
para essas galinhas
né todos os diabéticos independentemente
qualquer coisa podem fazer remissão não
tem gente que não consegue e Antônio
porque o qu ou porque tem diabete tipo
um que é autoimune e já tá com
destruição das células Bet pancreáticas
né da parte endócrina do pâncreas ou é
um tipo dois de longa data que já não
consegue
mais voltar no tempo e teve também
destruição de células Beta e essa pessoa
já não consegue mais recuperar do
diabetes mas todo mundo não é um grupo
específico que ainda tem reserva
pancreática pesso pessoas com diabetes
tipo um tem expectativa de vida de 52
anos Depende se for bem controlado o
diabetes tipo um pode viver muito mais
do que isso tá se for um diabet tipo mal
controlado seria mais ou menos isso sim
ok Como saber se teve destruição das
células que células tá falando Não
entendi Antônio é é bom que vocês ah
células betas quer dizer
né a maneira de descobrir isso através
de exame de
insulina de jejum glicose de
jejum e também índice
oma e também verificando tá a proteína C
tá a proteína C da da insulina tá bom aí
você consegue verificar se a pessoa tem
reserva pancreática ainda
mais perguntas
pessoal viu Antônio entendeu eu não vou
encerrar o canal tá eu não vou encerrar
mas eu vou reduzir minha
produção e vou tentar descobrir um jeito
de chamar a atenção do Povo porque toda
vez que eu invento uma coisa diferente
nesse canal queer para cara
impressionante uma vez você tem uma
ideia eu gravei uma Gam Play num jogo de
realidade virtual que tinha muito de
cogumelo no jogo e eu fui falar de
cogumelo com esse fundo do jogo o
pessoal diou essa maluquice que eu
inventei então também tentei fazer
vídeos falando do assunto do momento por
exemplo
lembra que o
ex-presidente Michel Temer foi foi
operar de próstata Eu fiz um vídeo
falando disso e linkando com o Michel
Temer como tinha Mita gente que não
gostava do Michel Temer teve um monte de
Hater e o vídeo Foi mal então toda vez
que eu invento alguma coisa nesse canal
eu quebro a cara esse vídeo como eu
falei o mais recente do picnogenol para
tratar disturbios menstruais era para
ter bombado vídeo curto vídeo com
storytelling vídeo com um monte de
imagens Não sei o que lá ilustrativas e
não e foi mal então eu não consigo
entender como é que é grado essa
plataforma
Ah eliz eu vou contratar sim tá bom aí
eu ponho na sua conta é baratinho viu el
você paga para mim viu
combinado é baratinho viu elizu essa
agência ma digital aí que você tá
querendo
aí tem ideia eu Dispensei a moça que me
ajudava entendeu com a o YouTube ela tá
ainda trabalhando para mim no Instagram
mas eu tive que fazer um Down grade lá
do pacote dela porque não tava valendo a
pena simplesmente não tava valendo a
pena pagar ela
entendeu Eu acho que pode ser
parcialmente isso Antônia parcialmente
não é o que explica 100% do problema mas
parcialmente
Tá eu já fiz esse curso ó ó pelo menos
uns 5 anos atrás el
eles todas as técnicas que falar no
curso já tentei eu não sei e eu tô há 8
anos ou mais no YouTube e até hoje eu
não sei o que que faz um vídeo bombar ou
não bobar porque é muito simples você
fala assim ah não faz uma f nail bonita
Ah faz um vídeo estruturado que o
roteiro bacaninha para as pessoas não
enjoarem para você não enrolar na hora
de falar o vídeo Faz uma introdução
bacana faz não sei o que lá tudo isso já
foi feito tudo isso já foi feito
tá mas você Ah mas não é assim el não é
não funciona assim cara os cara da
agência cobra fixo e você recebe
variável aí a conta não fecha Vocês não
tem noção entendeu vocês pensam que o
YouTube me dá um monte de dinheiro né
Vocês Pensa que eu tô julgando o
dinheiro ass uh entendeu PR cim porque o
YouTube paga para caramba né não é assim
infelizmente cara na maior parte dos
meus o anos eu paguei mais do que eu
recebi de volta do YouTube porque
comprar microf comprar câmera boa
entendeu investir em equipamento
investir em gente que te ajuda com fil
com miniatura comdição com não sei o que
lá entendeu Então teve uma fase do canal
que ele tava realmente bacana tá tava
dando um retorno Mas foi muito curta
essa fase uma fase que eu tava tirando
uma uma grana legal agora
só
entendeu Não é não funciona assim elizu
tá o o tudo é
extremamente irregular E especialmente
meu nicho porque se fosse o nicho de
viagem que eu tô falando Ah eu tô
visitando Tóquio agora tô visitando não
sei aonde e tal A pessoa que vê o vídeo
do do Tóquio ele quer ver o vídeo do du
ba quer ver o vídeo de Paris quer ver
vídeo de Barcelona mas eu faço um vídeo
de dor de cabeça o cara viu lá o vídeo
dor de cabeça porque ele tem dor de
cabeça ele não quer ver o vídeo cular de
fibromialgia ou não quer ver o vídeo lá
de natkin
entendeu é um problema cara não é m não
você terem ideia oan cebra saiu fora do
YouTube praticamente não é que ele saiu
fora ele fazia dois três vídeos por dia
agora ele faz um vídeo por semana no
YouTube por ele jogou todas as cartas em
cima do Instagram que ele tava tomando
porrada no YouTube também apesar de ter
6 milhões de inscritos é eu também acho
Estela também acho eu tô pensando
seriamente em fazer uns vídeos no tiktok
mas eu não sei se vai vai dar certo
senão sabe mas aí eu vou ter que fazer
outra coisa eu não vou eu não vou
colocar minha cara lá no tiktok e vou
fazer uns vídeos assim meio
eh não vou chamar de piada mas uns
vídeos assim bem mais humorísticos lá eu
vou fazer uma experiência talvez tá mas
eu não vou para minha cara tapa Não não
vou deixar minha cara lá no tiktok
porque eu perco a autoridade também se
for muito galhofeiro né tá
rapaz não é bem assim não viu Antônio
Não é bem assim na verdade eu já recebi
várias propostas assim de divulgar
produtos mas o conselho de medicina já
me chamou quatro vezes o codam que é um
órgão que regula a publicidade médica me
chamou quatro vezes lá no CRM de São
Paulo para encher meu saco porque eles
achavam que eu tava fazendo propaganda
irregular entendeu então assim eu
preciso de p espírito também se eu fizer
um acordo lá com patrocinadora o o ser
vai ficar me chamando uma vez por mês lá
me chando meu
saco essa fase que teve mais retorno
Eliseu foi mais ou menos com do anos de
mais ou menos 2021 tá então no segundo
ano da pandemia que foi a fase que mais
deu retorno que foi também por acaso a
fase que começou a dar problema de
strike do YouTube de apagar vídeo meu ah
teve umas duas lives que eu fiz com a
Luci que bombou muito deu muito retorno
Mas aí o YouTube começou a pagar os
vídeos tá então foi assim ficou poucos
meses muito bom aí o YouTube veio me deu
emp porrada foi assim aí eu comecei ter
problem de shad ban
É verdade Estela Eu também não queria
fazer vídeo assim falando assim tipo a
solução definitiva de todos os problemas
Ah eu não gosto muito desses títulos
assim eu sei que eu já fiz título assim
na Quem fez foi a A Helen me ajudando né
se não pagava a Helen mas cara não tava
a fim de fazer vídeo assim com esses
títulos assim sabe escalafobético não
mas talvez seja o caminho não sei eu não
tava a fim de fazer título
escalafobético mas pode ser né um
caminho
né pessoal para eu chegar naquele ponto
de fazer aquele vídeo é porque eu bati
cabeça uns dois anos vocês não estão
entendendo do anos batendo na cabeça não
foi 2 meses foi 2 anos então 99% da as
dicas que eu escutei ali eh no vídeo Eu
já tentei no passado Então não é porque
eu sou eu não tenho resiliência não eu
tenho resiliência tenho resistência e
resiliência Tá mas realmente não dá para
você ficar tacando dinheiro no canal e
não tá vendo retorno é complicado
tá
é eu também acho Marta eu acho também
ai
ai eu acho que tá bom já né pessoal tá
com 54 minutos de
Live que que vocês acham da gente
encerrar ou tem mais
dúvidas de nada Ant eu agradeço a
sinceramente a vontade de vocês ajudarem
eu eu entendo que vocês muitas vezes vão
dar sugestões que eu já tentei no
passado mas vocês não tem como saber
também que eu já tentei no passado Então
eu fico muito eh contente que vocês
estejam com tanto interesse de ajudar tá
inclusive vou até dar uma olhada lá
da dos comentários que eu não respondi
ainda que tem muito muito comentário
naquele vídeo
Obrigado
Estela pelo bom
descanso Obrigado Marta mas Fiquem
tranquilas eu não vou encerrar o canal
tá eu vou simplesmente reduzir a
produção de vídeos eu tô a fim de fazer
uns vídeos mais completos como eu fazia
antigamente no outro canal eu vou fazer
isso eu vou fazer vídeos aula de
PowerPoint do tipo que o Elise gosta no
outro canal igual eu fiz o vídeo do
penol e nesse vídeo eu vou soltar uma
coisinha outra é vídeo curto talvez
shorts Eu também muita gente não sabe
que eu tenho shorts eu recebi um monte
de sugestão falando para fazer shorts
como se eu nunca tivesse feito gente tem
uma porrada de short no canal é que as
pessoas não sabem que elas não foram
notificadas então o short não é a
solução porque muita gente não recebe
notificação do short ou não fica nem
sabendo do
short não Estela Fica tranquila tá e eu
sei que você teve lá esses dias no
consultório mas eu acabei não te vendo
né você estava com Ana Paula mas não eu
não vou encerrar o canal Fiquem
tranquilos eu vou e dar continuidade
mais numa outra pegada vou fazer o vídeo
quando tiver a fim do do meu jeito vou
testar umas coisas lá eu vou cagar pra
visualização também E vocês toda semana
eu vou estar com vocês aqui tirando
dúvidas tá E essa semana eu fiquei
devendo artigo mas semana que vem já
vamos voltar a discutir alguns artigos
tá bom Pessoal pessoal muito obrigado
mesmo pela pelo carinho de vocês pelo
afeto de vocês pelos comentários pelas
sugestões Tá bom muito obrigado mata
muito obrigado Estela Muito obrigado
Antônio Renato Muito obrigado
Eliseu tá bom Obrigado pelas dicas aí
tá seja abençoado também Manuel você e a
sua família tá bom Até a próxima pessoal
beijo no coração de vocês